maybe we should start by saying this
don't listen to anybody that's selling
you something
um
investment clubs buy my penny stock my
whatever crypto that I'm pumping I get
these DMS and emails all the time hey
help us promote this new crypto you can
make a lot of money in blood
there's 20 000 of those things out there
and
you know 9 19
998 of them are probably maybe even
more anyway so
let's get into some of the uh notes that
I've got over here because I got a full
page I want to rip through
they're in no particular order some of
these are things that you want to do
other things are just ideas and Notions
that you want to stay away from
um which I apply for the most part to
what I'm doing with my investing I
haven't I haven't made a vast Fortune
invest in money I think I've probably
made a lot more money
um running businesses and in crypto and
there's a few Investments that I've made
some good money off of but generally
speaking
I think where most people's heads go is
what stocks do I avoid avoid which ones
do I pick how do I invest how much to
invest time frames so I wanted to sort
of like put all these notes together to
sort of identify what I thought would be
the most useful information in uh
getting your head squared away around
this sort of stuff so
first note I have here is knowing your
time Horizon if you're
75 your investment strategies will be
different than if you're 25.
you got a lot more Runway heady when
you're a young man okay
um
knowing your time Horizon is going to
it should not everybody does but it
should play a significant role in how
you invest money what you invest in how
you invest in it
and the level of risk that you're
willing to take and because the markets
generally going up over time
it's not a straight line it's doing this
as it's going up sometimes it's doing
like this but
it it goes sideways and there's
things that are not predictable
nobody could have predicted well with
the exception of a handful people that
were obvious insiders in hindsight that
we know about but nobody could have
predicted the scandemic of 2019 that
they they pulled on us
um so there's certain things that will
that will fall in fall in your way but
knowing your time Horizon will play a
role you can take riskier bets when
you're younger you're going to take
higher yield bets when you're younger
there's a reason why old people mostly
don't touch crypto
because it's a longer term time Horizon
one and two they don't really understand
it
so there's a lot lots of things to
contemplate when it comes to your
your time Horizon but generally I think
General some good advice some generally
good advice is take bigger bets when
you're younger you can
screw up
and in two years be back exactly where
you were in 10 years you know
the sky's the limit you know essentially
for time Horizons but
whenever somebody's talking about things
like oh Bitcoin and I I just don't see
it it's just too volatile Rich you know
it's like well
if you're in and out if you're an in and
out sort of person or you watch it do
this in circles and up and down
especially over the last year it's been
all over the place
um yeah it's gonna look scary
but
my take is if you're not going to hold
it for four or five to ten years what's
the point in touching stuff like that so
again if you've got the time invest in
something that's longer term place so
there's that
uh there's a hell of a lot more than
just stocks and bonds everybody always
goes right to stocks and bonds which is
a good stock what's a good Bond do I put
this percentage into that and the other
thing look between the stock market
which let's be honest has got some play
in it some slippage it's got some
um interference you know if you will
with certain powers that be there's
things that are a little more
resilient to that Bitcoin for example
you can't really control it
um it's going to do what it's going to
do as long as people participate in that
economy real estate
there's that there's cars
um you guys know that I'm a big car fan
if you followed me for a while for my
entrepreneurs and cars Channel I watched
a video the other day Doug demuro
Captain uh quirks and features one of my
favorite
channels to watch still and he was going
through the duPont Registry that they um
pumped out 2008-9 during the last major
financial crisis and they were taking a
look at what certain low production
um desirable exotic cars were selling
for
um you know just over a decade ago and
some examples that sort of pop out in my
mind there was um GT40 Ford GT40 uh you
know 2004 2005 model could have bought
it for 108 000 uh you can't buy one a
nice one now for less than half a
million dollars USD
um there was Carrera GTS that were for
sale in 2008 2009
um a few hundred thousand dollars can't
buy one for less than a couple million
now so
like look Beyond just stocks and bonds
and it doesn't have to be you know a 300
000 career GT that you know is worth
over a million dollars now you can find
certain plays and Bargains in low
production High desire ability cheaper
type of cars even motorcycles you know
if you will there's there's there's a
certain motorcycle that I have my eye my
eye on I'm not going to mention which
one it is because I don't want to
express too much interest but there's a
certain motorcycle that I have my eye on
that I think will be valuable and I have
a connection to it so
there's certain things that you can
invest in that will go up in value over
Time watches too you know some people
love watches I'm not a big watch person
I've got some nice watches it's funny
like all the nice watches I have you
know were gifted to me I never really
bought watches but I I'm just not a
watch person I like cars cars and
motorcycles boats planes you know stuff
like that so you don't have to invest
just in the stock market so diversify
your ability to play in certain areas
there's there's some people I know that
play specifically just with high value
watches you know watches can make you a
lot of money so look for other
opportunities other than just stocks and
bonds is basically what I'm saying with
that point
um if you're if you're going to be
dealing with stocks
look I've I've played with the penny
stocks and my in one of my other notes
is avoid penny stocks I know that
there's
a significant amount of attraction to
penny stocks I've never made money in
them in fact they've almost always gone
bankrupt on me
um you know their value has either been
eroded erased they screwed up they never
went anywhere
um of course every stock probably
started out with a low market value not
always a penny stock I mean there's some
IPOs that come out initial public
offerings
um where they're not pennies obviously
they're they're in the dollar or
multiple dollar ranges or even higher
than that but penny stocks uh do get
pushed a lot because if you buy
something for two cents and it goes to
six cents oh wow I've just tripled my
money it's so easy for something to move
from two cents to six cents seems
attractive but the reality of is of it
is that it rarely happens there's always
guys out there that have programs to
sell in the penny stock area and I don't
pay a lot of attention to them on one
hand but on the other hand the attention
that I have paid to them I haven't seen
anything along the lines of okay here's
an actual screenshot of me buying this
penny stock for two cents with the
transaction you know on your whatever uh
trading account officially and here's me
selling it later on for this amount I
just haven't seen those
um I'm sure there's people that have
made some money off it but it's very
very high risk so if you're going to be
dealing with stuff like that you better
you better know what you're dealing with
and you probably want to figure that out
early on in your life in your 20s
because you're probably gonna lose a lot
of that money
um so back to the statement of large cap
something
a company that has a market
capitalization around five to ten
billion dollars is usually not going to
go anywhere unless it's run by a
complete bunch of morons in an industry
that's dying
um large cap businesses that aren't
going to go anywhere that I've invested
in
um there's a company that uh
oh was it called odimix or atomics I
can't remember how to pronounce it but
um there was a parent company that owned
Pratt and Whitney and an elevator
company
um large large growth opportunities that
come out of military conflict out of
building the economy because when you
build skyscrapers you need elevators and
all of these things so contracts come
out for them and they they need
maintenance as you build more and more
of these
um so if you're in a economy that's
growing where they're building a ton of
skyscrapers
there's probably lots of opportunities
to look for raw material suppliers
people that build elevators that
maintain elevators things like that
large cap companies out there that exist
that pay nice dividends uh that have
been around for a while that show steady
growth over time are good opportunities
and generally safer I'll put it that way
now
I'm not getting into the weeds here with
this sort of stuff these are just some
general ideas and some Concepts that
I've learned that I'm that I'm bringing
up to altitude on if you want to learn
about stuff like this
um lots of good books on it I'd say if
you haven't read economics in one lesson
uh Henry Hazlett I think is the author
um
very simple very straightforward covers
multiple areas from things like minimum
wage to economic conditions and
everything like that and it's not long
very very standardized sort of stuff is
a good starting point Ray Ray dalio if
you can find anything from Charlie
Munger even though he hates Krypton is a
bit of a in that area but he
understands Stock Investing
um Warren Buffett of course so guys that
have a proven track record that are old
not just salt and pepper but are like
completely gray at this point and the
autometers of the life that have spent
their entire lifetime investing I think
is probably a good place to get into the
weeds for stuff like that
um what other notes do I have here value
stocks
so Charlie munger's talked a lot about
his strategy around value stocks which
are generally reflected in a low price
low price to an earnings ratio
um
trying to give you some examples of
stuff that I've done in that
I think it's let me just pull it up real
quick on my other screen here
enjoy of doing these things live
don't listen to it
I think it was X
or they might have sold the company or
restructured it because that does happen
you know an interesting piece of
um stat that I came across
a few years ago when they first started
to put out these Fortune lists of like
the biggest companies with the largest
market caps
um it's been quite a few decades now I
think it's been well over seven decades
at least
um the number of companies that still
exist today from the original decade
when they started putting out that list
is very very small I think it's less
than uh 12 or 13 percent it's very low
most companies either get acquired they
go to business they merge
um some Deuce some come off you know
public ledgers so they so they go
private but for the most part they don't
really last for very long
that's it United Technologies was one
that I wanted to pull up utx is the um
uh is the actual stock symbol
um
companies like that
in opportune markets that that company
was a value stock
um let me pull up the chart here utx
chart and see if it goes back 20 years
that was a value stock just after 9 11.
um just trying to you know pull it out
of the utx chart why is it coming up
so it's a conglomerate conglomerate of a
whole bunch of companies under it jet
engines Pratt and Whitney uh automix the
um or atomics or whatever it's
pronounced the elevator company
uh what is the utx stock now it's still
it's not coming up utx why isn't it
coming up come on work with me here
Google
there you go so if I go to the max let's
see if it goes back to
2002. yeah so around 30 bucks is what I
paid for it and I think when I got out
of it
it was around the 70 mark
had a nice dividend yield it was well
Diversified in a lot of Industries to
um Aerospace defense
see the list of companies here
subsidiaries they even have subsidiaries
built within it uh 67 billion dollars in
revenue on an annual basis 182 000
employees in an industry that's always
going to need people and is always going
to grow over time as the economy expands
which it does it just it just like I
said the economy everything is growing
over time right so those are those are
the sorts of large cap value stocks that
you can do well and make quite a bit of
money in
would sit out today 103 dollars
well look you know the p e ratio is is
still reasonably strong with that too
it's actually not not a bad one and it's
probably worth looking at it but anyway
we're going to keep moving on value
stocks talked about that oh
um employer a lot of people don't take
advantage of this within companies I
know that when I used to deal with large
corpse when I was an employee back in my
20s
um they still offer these today but the
employer matchups or top-ups or whatever
it is that you want to call them
where you can
you can take a certain amount off your
paycheck and then the employer will
match up to a certain percentage of that
for free it's free money why wouldn't
you take advantage of that
if you're living paycheck to paycheck
and things are exceptionally tight in
your household you haven't managed your
money properly or you've mismanaged or
you've made some bad choices or thing or
some bad luck has come your way I can
understand why you may want to avoid
that but why would you not take
advantage of free and money an employer
is willing to put into your retirement
or investment account usually tax-free
if if it's structured properly or
complies with government guidelines
depending on where you live for example
but these employer top-ups or match-ups
whatever you want to call them you
should be maxing out on them when I was
an employee at the time I was surprised
at how few of my colleagues would take
advantage of the opportunity to get free
money from your employer
which goes into a reasonable Investment
Portfolio and again if you're if you're
younger if you're in your 20s and you're
only putting putting away a couple bucks
the employer tops up a couple bucks uh
you know per pay cycle maybe 50 maybe
100 maybe a few hundred I don't know but
if you put it in something that's got
strong growth and you're in your 20s and
you're at it for five six years you
could end up with a nice starting point
and that follows you you know wherever
you go you take it with you right
because it's in your name it's not it's
not the company's money the company's
giving it to you as a benefit of being
an employee with that company so take
advantage take full advantage of any
employer matchups top-ups
um I really hope you guys enjoyed that
clip if you want to watch the full
length podcast you can find that over
here that clips from if you're new to
the channel make sure you hit subscribe
over here and pin down below in the top
comment you'll find a bunch of useful
links to my website my supplement line
books and a bunch of other stuff have an
amazing day peace out